NICK BUTCHER: Good afternoon,
and welcome to the Android
Developers' Office Hours.
It's 2:00 PM here in London, so
it's your regular dose of
all things Android
development.
So, here in London, my
name is Nick Butcher,
and I'm joined by--
MATT GAUNT: Matt Gaunt.
Hi.
NICK BUTCHER: An international
show
coming to you from Jordan.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, G-Jordan
over here, where it's 5:00 PM,
believe it or not.
Richard Hyndman, as usual.
What's up?
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm on the stage at the G-Jordan
event, actually,
because it was the only
room that was free.
So I'm in somewhat
a large room.
There's absolutely no-one
here at all.
NICK BUTCHER: So have you
tracked down the only ethernet
cable in the conference
or something.
RICH HYNDMAN: The only ethernet
in this building.
It seems to be holding
out so far.
AL SUTTON: So it sounds like a
challenge-- how many people
can we get in that room by
the end of the Hangout?
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: Send them in.
And this is G-Jordan Advanced,
one step up from previous
years, where now you have to
actually be good to come in.
MATT GAUNT: What's it
gonna be next year?
It's gonna be, like,
[? super ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No,
advanced class.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, and it looks
like we have some regular
listeners, joiners, viewers,
whatever you want to call
yourselves.
[INAUDIBLE]
Al, we've not seen you
for a few weeks.
How are you?
AL SUTTON: Good, thanks.
It's good to be back.
And I've got December back in my
events, so I'm a happy man.
NICK BUTCHER: Ah, good man.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: And do you have
any [INAUDIBLE] hardware you
could show us?
AL SUTTON: I have a little
circuit board sitting below my
monitor, but I don't think
I can show it to you yet.
NICK BUTCHER: Aw.
AL SUTTON: It's a
prototype one.
But they're--
NICK BUTCHER: Tease.
AL SUTTON: All of the lucky
people who are going to get
dev kits, they're all shipping
out by the 28th of December.
So it should be arriving as
a New Year's present.
NICK BUTCHER: Just saying,
that actually
happens to be my birthday.
I didn't [INAUDIBLE],
but you know.
AL SUTTON: I'll put
you on the list.
I think you'll be
number 68,700.
NICK BUTCHER: There's
no birthday boost?
Oh, OK.
AL SUTTON: I'll swap
it for the next
generation of Nexus phone.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, you
got your Nexus 4.
NICK BUTCHER: Hello?
Is that Yossi?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I asked Al if
he got his Nexus 4 phone.
AL SUTTON: No, I haven't got
hold of one yet, but I believe
there's one winging
its way to me.
So by Christmas, I will
be a happy person.
NICK BUTCHER: You got your order
in yesterday when they
went back on sale.
AL SUTTON: Yeah.
I was lucky and got in, and
with the one- to two-week
delivery time.
NICK BUTCHER: Seemed to go a
little bit smoother yesterday
than the first time around.
AL SUTTON: There were a few
errors, but I mean, that's
what happens when you get
thousands of people pouncing
after the latest hot hardware.
So yeah, I don't think I've seen
anyone who tried to order
one who got an absolute blank
wall or mysterious things like
stuff disappearing from
their basket.
So it all looked a lot better
than last time.
NICK BUTCHER: You got
one, [INAUDIBLE]?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, I ordered
one [INAUDIBLE]
presents galore.
So yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
A few more regular joiners.
Johan, how are you doing?
JOHAN PELGRIM: I'm fine.
How are you?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, yeah,
very good, very good.
Johan, of course, from the
world-famous Dutch Android
user group.
We just came back from there two
weeks ago today, I guess.
We were there, weren't we?
Doing the live show from
Amsterdam, and a wonderful
event it was as well.
JOHAN PELGRIM: Yeah, it was good
fun for our second year.
Hopefully bigger and better next
year, so we're already
thinking about that.
So it's good.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
Who else we got there?
Mr. Christopher Banes.
CHRIS BANES: Hi, guys.
NICK BUTCHER: How
are you doing?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, good.
Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Still
not working?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, you
could say that.
It's not quite that easy.
MATT GAUNT: Very generous
of you.
AL SUTTON: There's a spot for
you in games consoles if you
want it, Chris.
Just come and have a chat.
NICK BUTCHER: And who else
do we have on the call?
I keep saying on the call,
like it's some
corporate VC thing.
Who else is hanging out?
We got Giuseppe there as well.
And how are you doing?
Ready to ask his Bluetooth
question, I'm sure.
And Matthew, I don't think--
is Matthew there?
Have you got a camera
or a microphone?
Can you say hello?
No, OK.
All right, then.
So as usual, we're here to talk
about all things Android
development.
We're not here to talk about
any future unannounced,
unreleased products and stuff
that we don't know anything
about, because we can make up
dates but we just don't know.
So there's no point in asking
us that kind of stuff.
But yeah, while we're here, is
anyone in the Hangout, live in
the Hangout, got any development
questions?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: Giuseppe
needs muting.
Let's get him.
I thought we should kick
off with the map
fragment, of course.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: Why don't you give
us a quick summary, Rich?
RICH HYNDMAN: Came to Google
Play services on Monday.
Google Play services making it
backwards-compatible with all
devices from--
NICK BUTCHER: 2.2.
RICH HYNDMAN: 2.2, which is
absolutely excellent.
They have to have OpenGL, too.
But I think every 2.2-upwards
device has OpenGL.
NICK BUTCHER: 90.8% of the
devices in the market.
RICH HYNDMAN: That must be all
the 2.2s upwards, right?
There must be--
NICK BUTCHER: Don't know.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
I can guarantee that it supports
100% of the devices
that it supports.
How's that?
So yes--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Sounds
good to me.
RICH HYNDMAN: Really not too
hard to implement at all.
You can just add the map
fragment in and you get all
the powerful capabilities of
Google Maps inside your
Android application.
It's all vector-based, finally,
so none of those
bitmap downloads that caches
to the external memory.
You can have the satellite
imagery.
You can have traffic data.
You can do animations.
You can give the camera a new
location and tell it to
animate to it, or a
new zoom level.
[INAUDIBLE]
single line of code,
awesome stuff.
And the most complicated
bit is just getting
your maps API key.
And to be honest, once you've
done that once,
it's not too bad.
Just go to the API's console
and turn on Google Maps API
version [? 2 ?] for Android in
services, and then you can
create your own new Android
application, and off you go.
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Awesome.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: So has anyone been
waiting for a map, update
to MapView maybe?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: Doesn't
everybody?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I think it was one of the
biggest [INAUDIBLE] we've had
for a while.
And it's been baking for a
while, so we're quite excited
to be able to talk about
this, finally.
Anyone here taken a look
at the new APIs?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Just
started yesterday.
But hopefully until the end of
the week, I'll have a mock-up
to show some features I
wanted to implement.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Maybe I'll
open source it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely.
But it's quite a nice little
demo app, isn't there, that
comes with it, Rich?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: So [INAUDIBLE]
all the different APIs.
RICH HYNDMAN: Absolutely,
yeah.
There's some samples that come
with it in the Google Play
Services Samples folder in your
SDK once you download
your Google Play services.
Actually, there seems
to be another update
to it today as well.
Whilst I was doing the slide
onstage today, I said, all you
need is Google Play Services
version 2 and show them in the
SDK manager and it increments
it to version 3.
I don't know why that was in
there, but maybe there's been
a bug fix already.
So make sure you're using the
latest version of Google Play
Services, and you can
get yourselves
a support map fragment.
NICK BUTCHER: Wonderful.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's epic.
I think every app that I write
over the next, even Ultimate
Stopwatch, is going to have
a MapView in just because.
[INAUDIBLE]
make this time, I don't know.
I love it.
OK, so we can carry on now.
I just wanted to get that out.
We can go into the normal
Hangout stuff.
Does anybody else in the Hangout
have a question?
JOHAN PELGRIM: Yeah, I
do have a question.
I've already posted it
in the moderator.
When I use the Spotify app,
every list view has a spinner
on the right.
And when I click that,
a subview folds down.
And [INAUDIBLE] question maybe,
is that an acceptable
UI pattern?
Or are you maybe suggesting to
go for a popout or whatever?
And the second question maybe
is how to best do that.
NICK BUTCHER: When do you
see this in Spotify?
JOHAN PELGRIM: It's just any
list, if you look on the right
and you click on the
screen there.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, OK, that
kind of spinner,
the dropdown thing.
JOHAN PELGRIM: Yeah.
I think it's really cool to fold
out additional stuff for
every song or album
or whatever.
So my question is how
to best achieve
that kind of animation.
Do I add an extra few groups
holding that particular
sub-display in every list
item, make it few, or
visibility gone and then animate
it when I click it?
Or do I add an extra few
[? types ?] to the adapter?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
so I don't know.
I'd add it to each individual
child item.
But I'd do it as a ViewStub.
So it's only inflated and
actually in memory when you
need it, and then it
just animates.
The only way you can get the
animation is by doing the new
animation framework, though.
So what would happen is, as soon
as you go visible on the
item, you'll get a big gap
appear, and then it'll just
come [INAUDIBLE].
So you'll only get that nice
slide-in motion with the new
animation APIs.
JOHAN PELGRIM: And is that
backwards-compatible then, Chris?
NICK BUTCHER: In no way.
JOHAN PELGRIM: No way, OK.
NICK BUTCHER: So Spotify must
be doing something funky,
because it obviously works
on other platforms.
JOHAN PELGRIM: Yes.
CHRIS BANES: It will still work,
but whether it's exactly
the same user experience.
NICK BUTCHER: No, I'm saying,
so they get the nice
slide-down transition, right?
JOHAN PELGRIM: Yes.
CHRIS BANES: But even on devices
before Gingerbread?
NICK BUTCHER: I don't
know if I have any.
CHRIS BANES: I mean, so that
might be using [INAUDIBLE] old
Androids on that.
So they get a similar
experience, but
not quite the same.
NICK BUTCHER: Possibly.
I've invited Marcus, the
developer of the Spotify app,
to the Hangout to see the
main development.
But he hasn't joined yet.
We'll see if he pops in.
But yeah, I think those
are good suggestions.
Yeah, so the new animation
API you're talking
about, Chris, is the--
[MUSIC JINGLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Whoa.
[INAUDIBLE].
JOHAN PELGRIM: Yeah. it
was a [INAUDIBLE]
so sorry about that.
NICK BUTCHER: It's all right.
Yeah, the API you're talking
about, Chris, is the enable
animate layout transitions,
isn't it?
What's it called?
I can't remember
the name of it.
CHRIS BANES: No.
It's just the animations.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, but you
have to turn it on, right?
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE]
and all the rest of it.
Because layout transitions are
when you [INAUDIBLE] actually
add and remove views, if
I remember rightly.
And whereas if you use the
old-style animation API, and
so a very tight flip
[INAUDIBLE].
And you'll get different
experiences with sort of the
Honeycomb animation APIs.
JOHAN PELGRIM: OK.
So basically, in short, if
I understood correctly, a
ViewStub in the row layouts, and
only inflated when I need
it, and then animate with
the new animation APIs.
CHRIS BANES: Sounds
good to me.
JOHAN PELGRIM: And if the
Spotify developer pops in,
Nick, he might have a
pre-Gingerbread solution.
OK.
Thanks, guys.
MALE SPEAKER: And [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Aha,
and we're back.
What did we miss?
RICH HYNDMAN: Interesting.
I didn't miss you guys.
Maybe that's what it's like
when we drop out from the
London office.
Your picture stays there.
Nobody even knows you've gone.
It's just like [INAUDIBLE].
It's good to see this from
the other side of
the camera for once.
NICK BUTCHER: It just looks like
we just stopped talking
for a while and just--
RICH HYNDMAN: You're just
listening quite intently to
the answer provided by Chris.
NICK BUTCHER: Maybe
we'll do that.
If we don't know the answer
to something--
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: Good work.
NICK BUTCHER: But I was talking
about, Chris, isn't
that the new change you're
talking about?
Because for a little while in
the API, there's been you can
animate additions to
list view, right?
So every new item would
animate gracefully
[? rather than ?] just a pair.
But when you're actually
animating the bounds of an
item list view, there's a new
changing animation which you
have to turn on explicitly,
right?
CHRIS BANES: Cant' remember.
I don't know.
I haven't really
messed with it.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
Well, that's what I
thought it was.
MATT GAUNT: So, Johan,
when you--
JOHAN PELGRIM: Writing
it down.
MATT GAUNT: [? --try ?] to
do this, just let us
know what you find.
JOHAN PELGRIM: Sure.
MATT GAUNT: That'd
be quite cool.
JOHAN PELGRIM: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: So also, you
talked about it from the UX
point of view as well.
It's a slight abuse of it.
Like, I think the little
right-hand triangle dropdown
is pretty strongly tied, like
you say, to the spinner idea.
Like, the idea is that you push
this and you have this
fixed concept of what's
gonna happen.
You're gonna have this kind
of dropdown list come out.
So it's kind of a
riff on that.
I actually think it's OK.
It's kind of similar
to what the Google
Music application does.
So in [? stricter ?] terms, I
guess it's not the right kind
of affordance to show what's
going to happen.
But I think it's an
OK validation.
I think it's quite cool.
JOHAN PELGRIM: Yeah, OK.
Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Any other
questions for the Hangout?
AL SUTTON: I'm just wondering
how many people saw Romain
Guy's performance analysis.
That was a really cool post that
he put up, of [INAUDIBLE]
took it apart and showed
all the overlays
and stuff like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Has anyone else played around
with the Show Overdraw
developer option with
their own apps yet?
AL SUTTON: I haven't, but I
didn't even realize it was
there until I read his post.
It's absolutely awesome.
NICK BUTCHER: I posted
about it weeks ago.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's epic.
Somebody here at G-Jordan is
running it all the time on
their device.
I was quite amused to actually
see them use it
live all the time.
NICK BUTCHER: I ran it for
a couple of days on
every single app.
It's weird.
It's a bit matrix-y at first.
Like, all you can see
is red, blue, green.
After a while, it's just blond,
brunette [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, there's a
really nice thing, though.
For the slide-in draws, the
different slide-in draw
libraries, some of them
are leaving the
draw behind the view.
So as the view list scrolls,
you can still see the draw
behind it if you have the
overdraws turned on.
And some of them, as soon as you
slide it and it goes off
the screen, are replacing it
with a ViewStub and it
disappears.
And these ones, obviously,
aren't impacting the list view
scrolling performance, but
the ones that leave it
behind the list are.
So we tried three or
four libraries out
to see which ones--
guess what Google+ does?
Hey.
[INAUDIBLE].
YouTube, it disappears as soon
as the draw closes, and then
it adds the layout back in as
it starts working again.
MATT GAUNT: Nice.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes, it's a good
trick when you're using other
people's libraries to see how
efficient they've been by
turning on overdraws.
NICK BUTCHER: And has anyone
else tried tracer for OpenGL
[INAUDIBLE]
yet?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I did it.
NICK BUTCHER: It's pretty
cool, right?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, It's pretty
convenient to follow
all the tracing overdraws.
NICK BUTCHER: So for those of
who don't know what is it,
it's basically a tool which lets
you kind of go through
each frame that you're
rendering, step by step of
rendering operation, in
this article which
Al was talking about.
Romain Guy takes a look at
a Twitter application.
And you can step through each
drawing command, basically.
So you can see that he's
drawing a full-screen
background and then drawing
another completely opaque
background right on top of it,
and then I think a third,
actually, on top of that.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: So I mean, those
are just completely wasted
time spent drawing and memory
being copied up to the GPU and
all this kind of stuff.
So you can just get rid of a
couple of those calls and just
gain a little bit of extra
rendering time for each frame,
so you can hit your 60 frames
per second [INAUDIBLE]
performance.
It's a really cool tool to
understand exactly what your
app's doing.
Check it out.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, I think it
was just a really nice
walk-through of all
the tools as well.
Like, it's one of those things
where you can easily open them
and then just get blindsided
by so much information.
So it was kind of nice the way
he kind of explains what he
looks for when he's doing it,
as well as what you can kind
of see from it as well.
So yeah, it's definitely worth
checking out, because I've
definitely needed those sort
of things before, just gone
[INAUDIBLE]
too much.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so I think,
Yossi, you posted a
link to it, for those watching
the video later.
Check out curious//creature.org,
and--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Here,
I'll post it on the
Hangout on Google+ also.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh cool.
Yeah, that's awesome.
RICH HYNDMAN: So I guess we
should stop Giuseppe from
having to wait any longer.
He's been waiting for an answer
to his question for two
or three weeks.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Yeah, but
before you started to answer
my question, I would like
to make my [INAUDIBLE]
public congratulations to Yossi
for a great job in data
application.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
Alfredo's making
too much noise.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: What is it?
RICH HYNDMAN: Carry
on, Giuseppe.
Sorry.
Alfredo joined, and he had some
feedback on his speakers.
We've just muted him, and
you can carry on.
Why were you congratulating
Yossi publicly.
Sorry.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Yes, because
they had an interview
on the TV, and they--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, we were
on CBS yesterday in the San
Francisco Bay Area, and
also reviewed by CNET.
[? JOHAN PELGRIM: [INAUDIBLE].
?]
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Yeah, that is
very good, because usually
the TV don't speak too much
about Android [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Very cool.
Good for you guys.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Congrats.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: So
where is my answer?
RICH HYNDMAN: OK,
I'll jump in.
Do you want the short version
or the really short version?
It's not good news.
So I've been looking into it.
There's only three Bluetooth
profiles that we enable you to
interact with directly.
And [? OPEX, ?] object file
exchange isn't one of them.
So the file exchange is provided
at a Bluetooth stack
level, and other devices can
inquire to see if your device
supports it.
And if it does, the file
is handled and stored.
There's no way of interacting
or interrupting that process
inside Android without--
yeah, from an external
application that you don't
own, sending a Bluetooth
file through [? OPEX ?]
to your application, it's
handled by the device.
So you can have it inside your
application, that you detect
Bluetooth devices and that you
make a serial transfer.
But if you want someone to be
able to do share via Bluetooth
and do an object exchange
file transfer into your
application, then this isn't
supported at the moment.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
interrupt this.
It's a system-level thing.
The only ones you can play
with are [? HUDP ?]
and [? health ?]
and headset.
That's three profiles that
your application
can interact with.
But the other profiles that
Bluetooth provides--
networking, file exchange,
things like that--
don't have APIs.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Frankly
speaking, after longer
research, I am [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
yeah.
Sorry.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Thank
you very much.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, good.
I think we need to welcome
Alfredo into the Hangout, at
Politecnico di Milano.
Hey, guys.
We muted you.
so if you'd like to say
hello, you can unmute.
Maybe Alfredo there can--
ALFREDO MORRESI: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, yeah,
He's here.
ALFREDO MORRESI: [INAUDIBLE]
hi, guys.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ALFREDO MORRESI: Hey.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
ALFREDO MORRESI: We are here
in the Google office in
Milano, together with some
guys from the university,
Politecnico of Milano.
And this is our first tentative
to run Hangout with
the university.
It's a new kind of initiative.
Today, we had some questions
from the guys, so if you want,
I can leave the part to them.
So please.
RICH HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
Welcome, first of all.
Welcome, all of you.
Thank you for joining us.
Let's take one question from
you guys to start with.
Then we'll take one for the
moderator, and then we'll come
back to the floor again,
see who has questions.
So who'd like to ask
a question from
Politecnico di Milano?
Google Office, as you say.
ALFREDO MORRESI: So does
someone want to start?
Please, go.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello.
I have some questions about the
Google Cloud Messaging,
about how can we use it to send
[INAUDIBLE] notification
and how we can manage when the
user is not online, and how
can we [INAUDIBLE]
the notification and send a
huge notification about
something that the user doesn't
receive when he or she
is offline?
MATT GAUNT: Who wants
to take that one?
NICK BUTCHER: Go on, Rich.
RICH HYNDMAN: So Google Cloud
Messaging, I assume you've
looked into the documentation,
the initial documentation,
which says how it works.
You build it into your
application, and then your
application registers with your
server to say that this
[INAUDIBLE].
And then your server sends
notifications to our server
when you want to send push
messages to the handset.
So anything outside of that
flow, you would have to
implement yourselves.
If you want to know if the
handset is online or not--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes,
[? sir. ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: I mean, the
notifications will get sent to
your application regardless of
whether your application's
open or not.
But if the handset's not online,
it's very hard for you
to detect the situation, because
you can't necessarily
tell your servers that the
handset's not online, because
it's not online.
It doesn't have a connection.
So the only thing that we have
in our toolbox that really
helps with this is you can send
the message, and when the
handset comes back online,
it will receive it.
But you can also set the time
to live for the message.
So you could say, this
message is only valid
for the next 10 minutes.
And if the handset doesn't come
back online in the next
10 minutes, then your message
will be discarded.
And then you can try sending
another one later on.
But you won't know.
I mean, it's going to be very
hard for you to tell whether
the handset's online or not,
unless you're keeping an open
connection to the server, and
when that connection stops,
you can assume it's offline.
But we wouldn't recommend that,
because that's just
going to drain the battery of
the device very quickly.
Al's just posted the GCM
docs as well for us.
But yeah, GCM, you can
now have up to
four-kilobyte payload.
So you can send some data
along with the message.
You can message up to 1,000
users at once, now that we
have these new JSON
file formats.
And I don't really
have a perfect
solution for your scenario.
Can you explain more about
what you're doing?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Well, I'm
developing the application
about the [INAUDIBLE].
And they need to receive a
notification where the
[INAUDIBLE] is [INAUDIBLE]
Italy or in a particular
zone [? over Italy. ?]
And we [INAUDIBLE] push
notification, they can receive
the notification about the
particular zone, or the
particular [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: I would be tempted
to ignore the case
that they're offline and
just send it anyway.
And as soon as their phone comes
online, they'll receive
the notification that this
bird has been seen.
Hopefully they're online and
they can catch it at the right
time to maybe go and
see the bird.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Because if they
are offline and then they
came online, they receive
a lot of notifications.
I want to delete all the old
notification and send only one
about all the updates that
they have missed.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, in which case
what you want to do is
just use your notifications to
say that there's an update
waiting for them.
So even if they receive
10, we'll bundle
them together anyway.
But even if they receive 10, all
that the application knows
is that there's some new
information for them to read.
And then the application goes
to your server and finds all
the updates.
NICK BUTCHER: Or there's the
collapse key, right?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
absolutely.
NICK BUTCHER: So you can set a
collapse key, which means,
while reading through the docs,
it's used to collapse a
group of messages.
So it's for exactly this case,
when a device is offline.
It'll just get the last
one from that group.
RICH HYNDMAN: But the important
thing is that all
those messages would have
contained [INAUDIBLE].
So you don't actually want
to lose any data.
So if the only data you're
sending is the fact that
there's been an update, then
you can collapse all those
anyway and just--
NICK BUTCHER: Exactly.
RICH HYNDMAN: --get the phone
to hit your servers to find
out what the update is.
NICK BUTCHER: Indeed.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK?
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK, thanks
very much.
OK, let's move on to
a question from
the moderator then.
One of you guys in London
have a moderator open?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: God, you're
organized.
NICK BUTCHER: But it's
just refreshing.
Great.
Any live questions while
we're waiting?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah,
I have one.
NICK BUTCHER: Go, Yossi.
Go.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Image filtering,
the render script,
as I saw, a render script
was deprecated in 4.2.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS BANES: Only the display
render script.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
So basically any suggestions on
how to apply filtering to
images [INAUDIBLE]
render script?
[INAUDIBLE] deprecated
that part.
NICK BUTCHER: No, filter
script's not deprecated.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Really?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, only
the kind of OpenGL
drawing tool kit.
The actual image processing
stuff, that's
very alive and kicking.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Oh, OK, because
I didn't really get into it
very much, just started to--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, no, it's
definitely still live.
If you look at filter script,
it's like a subset of the
entire render script
specifically aimed at doing
image processing.
So that's definitely something
that's being
actively worked on.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
And that should be
still alive--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, it was
just updated in 4.2.
I don't know the best places
to look at examples.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, Al just
posted the link on chat.
Thanks, Al.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, exactly.
Render script compute.
Render script examples
are always a
little bit tricky, right?
And render script
documentation.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, that was a
great talk at Google I/O by
Jeff Sharkey called Doing More
With Less, I think, where he
gave a good example of using
render script for doing--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah,
I've been there.
I saw it also live.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, OK.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: That's what
started my intrigue to looking
more into it.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
Interesting, this device here,
the Nexus 10 as well is the
first device to have hardware
support for render script
built into the GPU chip as well,
so it's phenomenally
fast through that kind of
operation on this device.
So hopefully [INAUDIBLE].
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Cool.
Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, let's take a
question from the moderator,
one which Matt hopefully
knows the answer to.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: So Damien
[INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]
says, is there a way to form an
intent so that if the app
is not installed, it'll
go to the Play store?
So he knows about you can,
in advance, use Package
[? Manager ?] to say, is there
a app for this intent.
But he's saying he's actually
flinging the
intent to a Google TV.
So he said he can't
do that two-stage
check and then launch.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, this isn't an
ideal way of doing it, with
trying to work on something
different that will hopefully
allow the assistant to basically
go, this isn't
installed, and then it'll give
you a kickback that says, no,
it's not installed, or actually
just go straight to
the Play Store and say we
already know what you're
trying to do, so we'll go and
grab the app for you.
At the moment, the [INAUDIBLE]
library doesn't support that.
So it's kind of a bit of an odd
situation, where you can
only just ask the user where
it's got installed.
Or yeah, I'm not
entirely sure.
I think the best solution that
I can come up with is try and
launch the application, and
then try and have some
communication with it, [? by ?]
your own proprietary
sort of solution.
Because when you use [INAUDIBLE]
protocol, you can
get the IP address of the Google
TV, so try and connect
through it through that.
And then if you can't do that
because your app isn't there,
then try and install it.
But there's not a really
nice solution for it.
I think we've kind of catered
towards the [INAUDIBLE]
you've got both apps
installed.
Or if you've got one APK, then
it kind of simplifies things a
bit, but not much.
So short answer, there's no nice
solution at the moment,
but we're working on it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
OK Cool.
Do you want to go back to
another live question?
Anyone in the room, or back
to the Milan office?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes, I
have a question.
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: I wanted to know
if our GPS model works for
[INAUDIBLE].
I want to know if a user,
when I [INAUDIBLE]
model, it computes my position
every instance or every
interval of time.
Or it is used only when I
call an app that uses.
For example, when I
open Google Maps,
it computes my position.
When Google Maps is not open,
GPS continues to work.
So it is in a [? freezing ?]
state.
NICK BUTCHER: So I guess the
easy answer is the GPS is only
fired up when an application
asks for the GPS provider.
So it's not going to be running
when an application is
in the background, unless
background status or something
is [? calling the ?]
GPS.
Does that make sense?
MALE SPEAKER: OK, but this
is for [INAUDIBLE]
because I think that
[? some users ?], when wanted
to save power, turned
off the GPS.
And my app used GPS a lot.
So [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: So how do you get
around it when the GPS is
switched off?
Can you access the
[? cross-location? ?]
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So you won't be able
to get [INAUDIBLE]
GPS lock if the user's turned
off the GPS setting.
That's exactly right.
This is why you kind
of want to be able
to handle that case.
And you can use either the
criteria object, [INAUDIBLE]
when you're querying the
location manager, you can pass
it a bunch of criteria which
describe the kind of fix
you're looking for and the
accuracy you're looking for.
And it'll give you
the best thing.
Or you can actually tell it you
want a GPS provider, in
which case it's just not gonna
work because it's turned off.
So yeah, the best advice is
always to kind of start from
the most coarse fix and
then wait while
it gets better fixes.
As always, we tend to point
people towards-- there's an
awesome couple of blog posts by
Reto Meier on our Android
Developer's blog called Location
Best Practices, where
he open sources a bunch of code
which walks you through
exactly the right
way to do this.
Or a couple of people have
taken all this code and
open-sourced it in a couple
of library projects.
So if you look at one called
Novocation on GitHub.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, that's the
one from [INAUDIBLE].
And then there's the little
fluffy [INAUDIBLE] one.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: I can't remember
what it's called.
NICK BUTCHER: So there's a
couple of libraries which will
just do the right thing,
so it'll do
exactly what you want.
They'll give you the course
location first and then
they'll on updating with better
and better location
updates as they get them.
So if the user has turned off
the GPS provider, you may
still get a pretty good fix
from the course location
provider, which is going to use
things like cell towers
and Wi-Fi hotspots to
triangulate you.
MATT GAUNT: So I think Al's put
in Reto Meier's blog post,
the link to Novocation
library.
I'm sure he's busy finding the
third link as we speak.
AL SUTTON: Yeah.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: At least you
use Google to search.
NICK BUTCHER: Does that answer
your question at all?
Or am I missing the point?
MALE SPEAKER: I don't think
you did, and I didn't
understand.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Ah, yes,
yes, but can
I ask another question?
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
If I want, for example, to
enable Wi-Fi or GPS, can I
turn [INAUDIBLE]
my model without asking
the user?
I [INAUDIBLE]
my [? money ?], because
[INAUDIBLE]
I [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, there's
a way to do
Wi-Fi, but not for GPS.
But I wouldn't advise you
to just [INAUDIBLE] turn
Wi-Fi on and off.
That's the kind of behavior
which users tend to not like,
when you're kind of changing
these system-wide settings,
unless you explicitly have
a Wi-Fi toggle button.
And in that case, that's
not so bad.
But if you're just [INAUDIBLE]
in the background, changing
the settings, I probably
wouldn't do that.
The [INAUDIBLE]
is to, if you look at something
like Google Maps,
it'll say you got Wi-Fi
off for a better fix,
and turn Wi-Fi on.
And if you click the thing,
it doesn't turn Wi-Fi on.
It sends you to the Wi-Fi screen
where the user can turn
it on, so the user still
feels in control.
While you do have technically
the ability, given that you
asked the right permission to
turn Wi-Fi on and off, I
wouldn't advise it.
I would probably prompt the user
and say, hey, why don't
you turn on Wi-Fi to obtain
a better fix.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, thanks.
ALFREDO MORRESI: Yes, if I can
add something to these
questions, it's also better
to ask the user to turn on
manually Wi-Fi, because you
don't know the context in
which Wi-Fi is in.
Maybe it's in a public place,
in a home, a coffee
[INAUDIBLE].
So you don't know if the user
needs to configure the Wi-Fi,
so just [INAUDIBLE]
to [INAUDIBLE] a stable
connection.
MALE SPEAKER: And what
[INAUDIBLE].
ALFREDO MORRESI: GPS
is the same.
But GPS is different, because
you can ask to the people, to
the person, if you can bring
[INAUDIBLE] to the GPS setting
[INAUDIBLE]
and then manually
activate GPS.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Can
I ask a question?
Giuseppe.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, go for it.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Thanks.
I have a work service that
sends unlicensed
email to the user.
I would like to know if there's
any chance to reduce
that my application to make
possible to open an attachment
in that email automatically?
I mean, can I register some MIME
type or some extension
type to make possible from the
Gmail application, for
example, to open the attachment
through my
application?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI:
Very good answer.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE] you
activity, you can have an
intent filter, which will
activate on URLs.
So for example, we use
it inside YouTube.
So all youtube.coms, when you
click on the link, opens
inside the YouTube
application.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Yes, which
this works when there is some
link or some URL, but
not in attachment.
I tried it already.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, but you have
to put a link or a URL.
This is the only way that I know
of, is context for a link
or a URL like this, that the
application will get launched
from another application.
NICK BUTCHER: But you can also
say you handle a certain
extension type as well?
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI:
Yeah [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: You say you can
support a specific MIME type
and then you just need
to make sure the--
yeah.
Would it be just the file
extension that would do that?
Or would you need to set
the file MIME type?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, you can
just do the MIME type.
But then every time an image/png
is offered, it'll
offer up to your application
to open it.
Maybe you could have your own
MIME types, [INAUDIBLE]
[? pro/image ?]
and then set the MIME type
of this in the email.
You could try that.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, if you can
control with both ends, then
yeah, definitely
you can do it.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, if you
have the email and the
application.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Yeah, because
I think that the
filter is not working
on the extensions.
It's working on the MIME type.
So you mean that I must send it
from the server, the file
with the MIME type already
there, right?
MATT GAUNT: I would've
thought so.
RICH HYNDMAN: I would play
around with that.
I'm not quite sure.
Inside an email, when you embed
an attachment, you can
specify the MIME type, right?
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Because I
created the file at runtime,
so probably I can create
my own MIME type.
MATT GAUNT: I'd have a play.
I think the difficulty might
be if the email client then
tries to guess what
the MIME type is
regardless of you've been.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: That is
another problem, yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, I think it
definitely feels like it
should be possible, but you need
to play around with it to
find the exact way to do it.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: If there is
any idea or any suggestions,
can I have some link ,
somewhere to look?
[INAUDIBLE].
AL SUTTON: It's down in the
right-hand side of the chat.
I've put a link to where you can
find the MIME type section
of a data tag that you can put
it in a intent filter.
And if you register for the
action of view , you should be
able to get your application
fired up when anyone tries to
view anything with
that MIME type.
CHRIS BANES: I'm pretty sure the
email application will try
and guess the MIME
type, though.
So it won't give you
a full MIME type.
It'll be a wildcard type.
So you'll have, like, audio
slash star or asterisk,
because it'll try and guess
and it won't really know.
So I don't know.
It depends what type of
file you're sending
and trying to open.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Tried already
with [INAUDIBLE]
type or with the extension with
the MIME, tried to use
all the [INAUDIBLE]
that are out there in
the documentation.
But [INAUDIBLE]
attachments.
I'm [? sure. ?]
MATT GAUNT: What extension
is your attachment?
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: I just put
an extension like txt, and
also the same I cannot open from
txt, simple txt files.
I started to try to do it with
my own extension, like LIC or
LWM, something like that.
Then I found it possible.
Then I tried to txt, text file,
but no way to register
my application with the
[INAUDIBLE] open attachment.
Yeah, I can just go to some link
with the MIME type, et
cetera, and the application
would not be
[? needed ?], for sure.
But the attachment, this is not
working at all, I'm sure.
AL SUTTON: Have you tried using
path [? pattern ?] for
your extension type.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Yes,
attempted to.
AL SUTTON: Yeah?
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Yes.
I have an intent filter that
this long one kilometer now.
I have tried it with the
asterisk// and the backslash,
anything, all the patterns.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: [INAUDIBLE]
a question for
next week again, OK.
NICK BUTCHER: So what about
[INAUDIBLE] because you're in
control of the other side
of it, what about
doing it with the URL?
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: WIth URL?
Just link the user to click
on some link [INAUDIBLE]
you mean?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Yeah, that
really is a workaround, yes.
I was just looking if I can open
the attachment directly.
AL SUTTON: Because you can
append parameters to a URL, so
you can pass all of the
information you were putting
in your file in that URL.
NICK BUTCHER: Exactly.
It would just get delivered to
your app in the intent, the
launching intent.
You'll be able to get the data
filled with the launching
intent and grab the
activation code or
whatever it is from there.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Do you mean
that to store the file on
somewhere, on the server,
and to make the user
download it, no?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
I was suggesting, instead of a
file, why don't you create a
URL which includes the
activation code, or whatever
the license file is, containing
in the URL itself
as a parameter.
AL SUTTON: I put an example
in the chat.
NICK BUTCHER: Sorry?
AL SUTTON: I put an example in
the chat of the kind of thing
I think you're meaning.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AL SUTTON: So you basically get
passed that long number at
the end into your app.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Al,
do you mean in the
[INAUDIBLE].server.com?
AL SUTTON: Yeah, that's right.
ALFREDO MORRESI: It's not
working, that link.
AL SUTTON: It won't do.
If you construct the URL
so that you've got your
[INAUDIBLE]--
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: Oh, sorry.
I was thinking that is a link.
OK, sorry.
Please continue.
Sorry.
AL SUTTON: No worries.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: So basically,
I found something on Stack
Overflow for all the
intent filters.
And the first link is
a bit way, way, way
more than you need.
And the second one I just
posted, the intent filters for
email attachments or
file browsers.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI:
Thanks, Yossi.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Also
the link is here.
Just a second.
Just searching for, registering
my app to open
email attachments.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI:
Second link?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: The
last link, yeah.
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI:
Thanks, Yossi.
Thank you very much.
This is [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: So what do you
think that we're missing then?
Because that looks like exactly
what we're talking
about, right?
Using the--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, the
attachment, but I think what
you missed was the view
default pattern.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, the
category default.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
Default for email and so on.
NICK BUTCHER: So give that
a try, Giuseppe.
And if that's not--
GIUSEPPE PORCELLI: I will.
Thank you very much,
[INAUDIBLE].
Thank you very much.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Also thanks to
Al, because his link was the
trigger to my search.
AL SUTTON: Hey, no problem.
It might be worth putting the
kilometer-long intent filter
on Stack Overflow somewhere
as well so we can all pick
through it.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, both of
them are Stack Overflow links.
So basically, you can check them
out, also post them on
the G+ page for developers.
MATT GAUNT: Cheers, Yossi.
NICK BUTCHER: Excellent.
MATT GAUNT: Cool.
Shall we go for another
moderated question?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Cool.
All right then, Rich,
you still there?
Because we gotta cover the
new map view questions.
I know you've been playing
around with it.
So Shane in Wisconsin asks, with
the new v2 of maps, is it
possible to get styled maps,
like the JavaScript API?
I saw there's an API for a URL
tile provider, where you can
provide your own tiles, but I
don't know if you could use
that with Google's JavaScript
Styled Maps.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Didn't try it,
but I saw that you can do a 3D
map and everything
on the fragment.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so
basically, what is quite cool
is that we do open up the
whole tile-rendering
architecture, so if you can
supply your own tiles, then
you can plug that into the
Google Maps engine and get the
whole two-fingered panning,
rotating,
in-and-out type behavior.
But do you know if you
can plug in, like, a
JavaScript API URL?
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE] our
APIs just allow you to create
your tile provider, so that when
we ask for a tile for a
certain location, you
can provide an
overlay for that tile.
And we also have a URL tile
provider, so that you can do
that direct from the internet
as well the URL format.
But we don't have the JavaScript
API for the maps on
Android, as far as I
know at the moment.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
no, I get that.
But he's asking, can that URL
for the URL tile provider be a
Google Maps-- is it compatible
with the Google Maps
JavaScript API?
Can you send it to us?
RICH HYNDMAN: That's
a good question.
You should try and link
that back around.
I've not seen anything in the
documentation that suggests
[INAUDIBLE].
It just says that URL tile
provider's a partial
implementation of tile provider
that requires a URL
that points to an image.
If you can somehow [INAUDIBLE]
that so that when--
it's going to call get tile
URL with a longitude,
latitude, and zoom level.
If you can translate that into
something that's using our
JavaScript API, then, yeah,
there's no reason why it
wouldn't work.
NICK BUTCHER: So yeah,
the short is we don't
know, but it sounds--
we haven't tried this yet.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: The longer answer
is, either try it, I
think, like Rich says, just
construct a URL which calls it
from the JavaScript [INAUDIBLE]
maps provider, or
perhaps go to--
I think [INAUDIBLE] holds a
similar Office Hours to this.
now he's been quite involved
with it, with the direction of
the products.
So if you look for the
GO Office Hours, or
@developers.google.com/live and
try those guys, they may
have a better idea than us.
Cool.
Any other questions live?
Should we go back to Milan?
MALE SPEAKER: I do
have a question.
I just started developing
Android for just over a month.
And my question is very broad.
Is there a recommended
development pattern, design
pattern for Android apps?
For example, I'm used to
developing in the [INAUDIBLE]
like the amount that you
control [INAUDIBLE]
pattern.
Is there a suggested pattern
for Android?
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE],
Matt.
MATT GAUNT: So yeah.
I mean, there are kind of set
ways of making life a lot
easier in the Android
platform.
So when you create your first
hello world sample, you'll
start noting that we create
values, files, select strings,
dimensions.
We have certain ways of
distributing images, so you
pick the right size to the
right screen density.
So you kind of want to stick
with things like
that as best you can.
But ultimately you also get to
a point where you are capable
of having the model view
controller structure as much
as you want to put in place.
But I'd strongly recommend that
as you start looking at
the documentation, we talk about
things like activity,
life cycles, fragment life
cycles, services, and it's one
of those things where you
definitely want to stick with
all of those rather than just
kind of saying, well, I know
how to do this in Java,
because a lot of those
suggestions are for
good reasons.
And they let are there generally
to make your life a
lot, lot easier by sticking
with the platform.
So yeah, it's a very open-ended
question, but I'd
say that if you look at the
really basic documentation on
activities, that's a really nice
place to start, as well
as resources.
That would be kind
of my suggestion.
There's obviously the
Android Academy.
I'm sure there's some awesome
tutorials for that kind of
stuff as well.
NICK BUTCHER: And training,
Android training.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, guys,
can I add something?
To me, what I'm facing is that
I see activities strongly
associated with their views.
And so it's like eve data, for
example, the key value store
that is offered by Android,
one of the versions is
attached to the activity
itself.
So to me, it seems as if each
activity is separate, and then
it's like you're designing
each activity by itself.
So that's what I'm feeling, is
that the user interface is
shaping the way the app
is being designed.
I don't know if that
was clear or not.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
AL SUTTON: I think we've lost
London again, which is why
they're not answering.
[LAUGHTER]
AL SUTTON: Either that or
they're doing a very good job
of sitting still.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh,
look at that.
They are, aren't they?
I'm supposed to take over
when that happens.
I was answering email.
Sorry.
Did someone who knows the
answer in the Hangout--
AL SUTTON: Yeah, I can take
it if you want, Rich.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
AL SUTTON: It used to be the
case that activities were
closely tied to the user
interface, so you'd stick with
one particular layout for each
activity, but frank--
user interface elements in and
out a lot more easily.
So if you're looking at
supporting older devices, so
pre-Android 3.0, so before
tablets and things like that,
you can focus on using
an activity with
a fixed user interface.
But if you want to support a
more modern look and look more
up to date, it's worth using
fragments and having a look
into fragment tutorials,
and look at the Android
compatibility libraries, which
would provide you with those
features on earlier
devices as well.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, thank you.
AL SUTTON: No problem.
RICH HYNDMAN: Thanks, Al.
Are you guys back
in London now?
MATT GAUNT: Just about.
NICK BUTCHER: Hey, yeah,
we rejoined.
Seems like you got a better
internet connection in Jordan
than we do in London.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, it's
not bad at all.
It's pretty epic.
I do have a room which
seats 1,000 people
all to myself, though.
I assume the Wi-Fi in here
is pretty damn good.
NICK BUTCHER: And a beautiful
backdrop.
RICH HYNDMAN: I'm well lit.
Moderator, maybe?
NICK BUTCHER: Moderator.
Chris in London says, if playing
with NFC tags and
using NFC rights on the Galaxy
Nexus, all works great, but
when opening a URL, only Opera
is listed as the chooser, even
though I have other browsers
installed.
Any idea why?
Links from Gmail get the
full browser list.
Thanks.
MATT GAUNT: So I guess it
depends on the URL opening
from the NFC chip.
Is there anything
weird about it?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I would
inspect the URL, the NFC tag
and look at what format the
chip's in, the URL's in,
because that sounds crazy.
I think there's a problem
with the NFC tag there.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
absolutely.
NICK BUTCHER: It's interesting
that Opera seemed to recognize
it but the other
browsers don't.
I mean, I guess you could
always [INAUDIBLE]
their registering [INAUDIBLE]
and see what they're looking for
and see why that wouldn't
work for other people.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, we need
a little bit more
information on that.
If you can grab the logs, see
what intents being fired or
anything, or if you know any
more details about the tag or
the MIME types, we could
look into it.
But there's not quite enough
information to figure out
what's going on with that one.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Any other live questions?
We should carry on.
CHRIS BANES: Was that the
NFC tag question?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: I missed it.
You only really receive NFC
intent if you register your
manifest through the intent
tag found intent, is it?
So I'm guessing only Opera's
actually added
that to their manifest.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: But then the tag
reader's actually reading the
tag, and then it's gonna just do
an open on the data of it.
CHRIS BANES: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: No, it doesn't
say that, actually.
It says he's using NFC writer
to write the NFC tag.
And then the Opera
is listed when he
tries to open it again.
NICK BUTCHER: Well, I know I
have nothing special installed
and I can launch URLs
straight from this.
RICH HYNDMAN: Absolutely.
So it sounds like his MIME
type's a bit funky.
Yeah, what tag are
you writing?
Not just any tag.
Tell us a bit more about the
NFC tag you're writing.
MATT GAUNT: One interesting
question that I've not really
considered how to do before on
the Google+ post, which was
someone's essentially, in their
layout, they've got a
view [INAUDIBLE]
[? field parent ?]
or wrap content.
And essentially, when they start
going to landscape, they
want to use a fixed dimension,
to 100 dps, say, that they're
putting in a dimensions file.
Now, what they'd like to do
is, on a phone, just then
switch back to match parent
or wrap content.
Now, I understand how I'd do
that in code, but I never
thought how you'd do that
for a dimensions file.
Anyone have any experience
trying to do that?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: [INAUDIBLE]
a dimensions file to--
MATT GAUNT: Wrap content
[INAUDIBLE].
Could you just set it to
minus 1 or minus 2?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, you
can set it to minus
1 or minus 2, but--
MATT GAUNT: But then that
would get screwed
up along the way.
Yeah, that's a weird
one that I've not
really thought of before.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
in code maybe, on
configuration change.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, on code,
it's configuration change.
But on XML, so you basically
must override on configuration
change on both ways.
NICK BUTCHER: Either that, or
you could just extract that
part of the layout into an
include and then have
different layouts for
layout-land and layout-port,
and the include will put
it in the right one.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah
[INAUDIBLE].
But basically, he mentions
a phone and a
tablet, or just a phone?
MATT GAUNT: No, he's
talking about doing
a phone and a tablet.
So what he's doing at the
moment is to have
two separate layouts.
Whether he's doing includes
or not, I don't know.
But I think, yeah, he was just
wondering whether that was
possible or not.
And it sounds a bit it's not.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I did it
once a couple months ago.
I did XML with minus
1 and minus 2.
And it worked, but
it's not a good
convention, I think, for--
MATT GAUNT: No, it
sounds a bit--
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
values v11 and put a REST XML
file in there, values v11
landscape, or whatever format
you-- oh no, values.
MATT GAUNT: What about styles?
Yeah, value--
RICH HYNDMAN: Values land?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
YOSSI ELKRIEF: You can
do layout-land or--
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: No, but you could
have values land and
values folder and have
a different style
in your styles XML.
MATT GAUNT: And then you
could do the match
parent or wrap content.
NICK BUTCHER: Which can define
the layout, width, and height.
MATT GAUNT: There you go, boom.
Nailed it.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah,
that's better.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE],
the styles.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So you're gonna keep working
on [INAUDIBLE] now Facebook
are doing the same thing?
CHRIS BANES: I don't
know, probably not.
Mine is bugs, so it's probably
feature-complete.
There's not anything else I want
to put to it, so I'm just
gonna leave it to
just be there.
So yeah, I mean, it was
only supposed to
be something I wanted.
It was a feature I wanted.
So it's just--
NICK BUTCHER: I didn't know,
it's their version that only
syncs when you open
the app, right?
Rather than just anytime you
take a photo, which is
interesting.
CHRIS BANES: Does it? don't
know, I haven't
even looked at it.
NICK BUTCHER: I didn't
look at it.
I just read the [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BANES: It's made for
backup, though, isn't it
[INAUDIBLE]?
It's more for backup photos.
That's what they're trying to
push [INAUDIBLE] rather than--
RICH HYNDMAN: That reminds me as
well, one of the potential
solutions to Giuseppe's problem,
which doesn't work
very well, was just to monitor
the Bluetooth files directory
for whenever a Bluetooth file
is dropped in there.
Basically, it'd be doing
something similar by
monitoring the images
directory.
That's what suddenly triggered
it in my mind.
I know the Bluetooth files
directory is slightly
different on different handsets,
but it's always
under the SD card.
You can get an external
directory and add
Bluetooth to it.
So Giuseppe potentially could
just look through new files
appearing in the Bluetooth
files directory and then
process them.
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE]
service open.
RICH HYNDMAN: Mm-hm.
Yeah, it's one of those
broadcast receivers
that needs a service.
It can't be registered
dynamically.
That's a shame.
I didn't know that.
OK, screw that.
[INAUDIBLE].
It was just an idea.
Just skip it.
NICK BUTCHER: OK, we got
one minute left.
We've got an interesting
question that's coming through
on the G+ thread, where
[INAUDIBLE] asks, can we
configure a sync adapter
to sync only on Wi-Fi?
Has anyone done this before?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, you can
just check your telephony
manager [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: That's one
approach, right.
So when the sync kicks in, just
check is Wi-Fi, and only
continue [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS: Well, just queue yourself
up to the next time
you cancel Wi-Fi, just
[INAUDIBLE].
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, basically,
but you have also a
setting on--
just a second.
CHRIS: Is there a setting
on sync adapter?
I can't remember that one.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
That's what I wanted to check.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's funny.
The guys in London, come 5
o'clock, they just leave.
That's really rude.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, they have
two minutes left, no?
They just punch a clock
and run away.
RICH HYNDMAN: That's amazing.
5 o'clock, boom.
AL SUTTON: Are you still
on your own, Rich?
RICH HYNDMAN: Am I sorry?
AL SUTTON: Are you still on
your own, or have we lured
anyone into join you?
RICH HYNDMAN: There's a
technician who keeps changing
the lights, and that's
just about it.
The problem is the session's
running all afternoon, so
there's people that--
--digging through the
Android Developer
documentation, right?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: It's like he's
digging through his own mind.
[INAUDIBLE]
represented on the internet.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: I know I had
another approach for dealing
without checking is
Wi-Fi on, or--
NICK BUTCHER: So I was going to
say, why don't you register
a broadcast receiver for
the Wi-Fi state change.
And when it gets turned off,
then you use package manager
to turn off your sync adapter.
And when Wi-Fi goes on,
you re-enable it.
Because that way, you're not
having to wake up, oh, Wi-Fi's
off, go back to sleep and
consume resources.
CHRIS BANES: True, but the
amount of time Wi-Fi goes on
and off, is it worth it?
I don't know.
It depends how often you sync.
Because if you're syncing--
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
worth it to me.
So I mean, whilst
I'm at home--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Basically when
the system sends all the
adapters the broadcast, because
if one sync adapter--
that's what Reto also had a
demo about how to use the
broadband and the connectivity
in a more efficient
way on 3G and stuff.
So basically when--
NICK BUTCHER: The Big
Cookie approach.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, yeah.
You basically smooch
on a different
adapter's sync event.
RICH HYNDMAN: Smooch.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, you
smooch internet.
CHRIS BANES: Smooching
with adapters.
NICK BUTCHER: On that bombshell,
we're unfortunately
out of time.
Thank you, everyone,
for joining us.
Nice to see some new faces in
the Milan office as well.
Thank you guys very much
for joining us.
I hope we answered some
of your questions.
Join us again at the same time
next week, or also check out
some of the other shows.
So we're going to have
TheAppPlanet going out on
Friday, more Design in Action
coming at you on
next Tuesday as well.
We're a fully packed schedule
at developers.googl
e.com/live/android.
So thanks again, and
see you soon.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]